la ingeo plástica coronaria también
denominada angioplastía coronaria
transluminal percutánea o angioplastia
con globo está diseñada para restaurar
el flujo de sangre de las arterias
coronarias estrechadas u obstruidas por
placas ateroscleróticas o coágulos
sanguíneos
cuando usted llega al hospital se le
colocará una vía intravenosa y un
monitor cardíaco y se le administrará un
sedante intravenoso u oral para ayudarlo
a relajarse la mayoría de los
procedimientos de angioplastía coronaria
duran entre 30 minutos y 3 horas el
médico anestesia la piel en la zona de
la ingle e inserta una aguja en la
arteria femoral una vez que se coloca la
aguja se pasa a un conductor a través de
ella y se lo guía cuidadosamente por el
sistema arterial hasta el corazón la
aguja se retirará y se reemplazará por
un tubo flexible pequeño denominado
vaina permitiendo el acceso a la arteria
femoral en este momento se le
administrará un diluyente de la sangre
para reducir el riesgo de formación de
coágulos sanguíneos luego un catéter
flexible y blando se desliza sobre el
conductor a través de la vaina y se
dirige hacia el corazón
el procedimiento se monitorea utilizando
un dispositivo que proyecta imágenes
continuas de rayos x llamado
fluoroscopio es posible que sienta
presión mientras el conductor en la
vaina se insertan por la ingle y se
empujan por la arteria pero no sentir
ese movimiento dentro de las arterias en
este punto el médico
tirará el conductor guía posicionar a la
punta del catéter dentro de la arteria
coronaria que se va a tratar e inyectar
a un tinte especial este tinte le
permite al fluoroscopio tomar imágenes
de rayos x- denominadas angiogramas del
interior de las arterias las
obstrucciones se identificarán
claramente a medida que las arterias se
llenen de tinte cuando se inyecta el
tinte puede sentirse acalorado o con un
poco de náuseas una vez que se
identifica la obstrucción el médico
insertar a un conductor guía flexible en
la arteria y avanzar a un catéter que
lleva un pequeño globo en la punta
pasándolo por encima del conductor guía
hasta posicionarlo en la zona de la
obstrucción al inflar y desinflar
rápidamente el pequeño globo se empuja
hacia fuera la pared del vaso sanguíneo
restableciendo el flujo de sangre de la
arteria es posible que sienta dolor en
el pecho mientras esto sucede el mismo
procedimiento se repite para cada
bloqueo tratado luego el médico retirará
el globo desinflado y el catéter de las
arterias algunos pacientes se les
colocará un stent coronario que es un
tubo pequeño de malla metálica diseñado
para mantener abierta la arteria una vez
que se haya tratado se coloca un stent
plegado sobre el globo desinflado
a medida que se desplaza hacia la
posición cuando se infla el globo el
extensa expande y queda asegurado en el
lugar después de retirar el globo y el
catéter el stent permanece como soporte
para mantener abierta la arteria de
forma permanente
después del procedimiento se le aplicará
un vendaje de presión sobre la arteria
femoral para evitar una hemorragia usted
deberá permanecer recostado boca arriba
por varias horas durante las cuales será
revisado continuamente en busca de
cualquier signo de hemorragia o dolor
torácico es posible que se le dé de alta
el mismo día o después de pasar una
noche en el hospital